- [Narrator] Europe hasn't had a hurricane
reach its shore in over 50 years.
Now don't get the wrong idea.
Hurricane season still brings
a hefty dose of wind and rain.
But Europe has something
that North America doesn't,
when it comes to protection
against hurricanes.
Location.
(light music)
Hurricanes usually form off
the coast of West Africa,
where warm water near the
Equator and high humidity
create columns of rapidly
rising rotating air.
It's the perfect recipe for a storm.
Now the more warm, moist air
that the system picks up,
the stronger it becomes.
That's why a tropical
storms can quickly grow
into a full on hurricane as it
marches across the Atlantic.
(soft music)
Now normally hurricanes are propelled
on a westward track by the trade winds,
caused by the Earth's rotation.
That's why Europe as well
as the West Coast of the US,
rarely experience full on hurricanes.
But that's not the whole story.
After all, since the year 2000,
remnants of around 30
hurricanes have reached Europe.
For comparison, Florida
has seen 79 real hurricanes
over the same time frame.
By the time these remnants make landfall,
they've went from a hurricane force,
to a tropical storm or weaker.
And that's where Europe's
location comes into play.
In order for a hurricane
to head towards Europe,
something crucial has to happen.
It has to travel really far
North by about 200 miles.
Once a storm system
reaches 30 degrees north,
it encounters the subtropical jet stream.
Which moves in the opposite
direction of the trade winds.
And therefore, blows the storm East
But because the storm
is now farther North,
the waters underneath are colder
by up to about five to 10 degrees Celsius.
Which means less energy
available to feed the storm.
And as a result, it starts
to die down by the time
it's headed for Europe.
Even though it's no longer a hurricane,
it still packs a punch when it hits shore.
In fact, most of these hurricane remnants
will combine with other nearby
cyclones and weather fronts,
that create high winds and rain
that mainly hit Ireland and Great Britain.
But have been known to
reach as far as Greece
or even farther in Northern Russia.
Typical damages include power outages,
flooding, and occasionally casualties.
Most recently the remnants
of Hurricane Ophelia
made landfall in Ireland
and Scotland in 2017.
About 50,000 households in
Northern Ireland lost power.
Three deaths were reported
and downed trees closed many
of the public roads and highways.
This was the worst storm that
Ireland had seen in 50 years.
And it may be a sign of what's to come.
As global surface temperatures rise,
it will also increase the
sea surface temperatures
in the Northern Atlantic.
Which researchers estimate
could contribute to an increase
in the number of hurricane
force storms that reach Europe.
Some experts predict that by
the end of the 21st century,
Europe could experience, on average,
13 powerful storms each year
during hurricane season.
Compared to the two per year it sees now.